Ali and her best friend Raul have caught
their parents having an affair but Raul
refuses to talk about it in this scene
Raul finally calls alia who was in the
middle of spending some quality time
with the new kid in town Varun interior
tyagi house Farren's room de alia
straddles a shirtless Varun on his bed
he reaches under her shirt as they make
out alia cellphone rings they ignore it
interior Singh house rolls room Day
rolls room is huge decorated with
posters of sports cars sports teams
stacks of fitness magazines roll flexes
in front of his mirror as the phone
rings it goes to awliyas voicemail he
hangs up impatient and immediately dials
again intercut between Varun room and
rolls room alia groans and looks at her
phone oh damn it it's Rogan he's been
calling for days she answers continuing
to straddle Varun who waits in minor
agony hey Rob what's up what's up what
do you think did you drop off the face
of the earth I'm sorry I'm just I'm so
grossed out aren't you grossed out yes
oh yeah it's grody to the max well what
should we do nothing there's nothing for
us to do let him figure it out [ __ ] [ __ ]
it [ __ ] it yeah so so what we just
pretend we don't know that they groped
each other look I get that it sucks okay
remenber I'm in this with you
in fact I'm probably the only one who
knows exactly how you feel so stop
avoiding me okay we just need to make
sure we're okay it shouldn't change
anything between us right I guess
cool so you want a carpool tonight
Caitlin Josh said they'd be around 7:00
tonight the movie oh I don't know if I'm
going I might be hanging out with Varun
well you want to invite Varun to tag
along okay Varun would you like to come
see a movie with all of us tonight I
can't I have to work
Vernon has to work oh I guess I'll see
you tonight that I'll meet you guys
there
okay okay but they hang up she looks
down at Varun you okay
I don't know you want to talk about it
I'm on top of you and you're asking if I
want to talk we can do other stuff too
if you want yeah we can talk after later
Varun and alia lie in bed post-coital
their own strokes alias hair alia looks
around his room cozy warm small you have
a lot of books hmm yeah you guys do too
no but they're fake you're fake yeah my
mom bought all these sets from the
interior designer they're in Swedish or
something and most of the pages aren't
either but they just matched our brush I
didn't even know that was a thing oh
it's a thing Raul's family has some in
blue you live in a strange world